des
07 de six secousses hospital
of the world child de death to come
to be
more jeff
morris offering and the strokes
et on va tout de suite prend la
direction de bruxelles où nous attend
notre correspondant jean jacques guéry
bonjour jean jacques sans surprise
l'otan a donc condamné la guerre
illégale de la russie en ukraine a
qualifié d'illégale et inhumaine
oui elle a condamné cette guerre mais
par la voix de son secrétaire général
jens stoltenberg l'otan a surtout
réaffirmé sa volonté de ne pas être
parti dans le conflit qui se déroule en
ukraine c'est l'aspect le plus important
je crois qu'il faut retenir de cette
réunion est de fait aucune grande
décision n'a été prise ce matin par
l'alliance on sait que ces derniers
jours des appels avaient été lancés à
l'automne pour imposer une zone
d'exclusion aérienne au-dessus du cren
les no fly zone et bien cette idée elle
a été rejetée en droit international il
faut savoir que c'est considéré comme
une mesure offensive une mesure de
belligérance et sa l'alliance ne veut
pas elle ne veut surtout pas être parti
dans le conflit jens stoltenberg l'a
répété plusieurs fois ce matin les
alliés sont d'accord pour dire qu'il ne
peut pas y avoir d'avions de l'otan dans
les ciels craignant ni de troupes de
l'otan sur le territoire ukrainien voilà
ce qu'il a dit pas question donc de
rentrer directement en confrontation
avec la russie l'otan veut paraître
comme une organisation défensive qui
défendra son territoire un mini rapaces
battre en dehors et n'ira pas
frontalement se battre contre la russie
nous devons éviter l'escaladé en dehors
de l'ukraine c'est ce qu'on a entendu
tout à l'heure alors comment eh bien les
moyens ils sont déjà à l'oeuvre avec ses
milliers de militaires supplémentaires
déjà déployés dans le cadre de la force
de réaction sur les frontières est de
l'otan il y à des nouveautés à l'oeuvre
tout de même comme le renforcement de la
coopération et le partage d'informations
avec deux pays qui ne sont pas membres
de l'alliance la finlande et la suède
mais désormais stockholm helsinki
assisteront à toutes les réunions sur la
crise ukrainienne enfin il ya un autre
aspect intéressant du discours qu'on a
entendu tout à l'heure de ce discours du
secrétaire général de l'otan c'est sa
dénonciation de la volonté du kremlin de
recréer une sphère d'influencé très
clairement jens stoltenberg l'a dit en
réaction il faudra se rapprocher très
vite de ce qui la définit comme des pays
à risque la géorgie et la bosnie
herzégovine et la résumer les choses de
la manière suivante la relations de
l'otan avec la russie a finalement
changé fondamentalement changé et cela
s'inscrit dans la durée même s'il faut
que les canaux diplomatiques demeure
ouvert donc pas de décision à l'otan ce
matin il y en aura peut-être tout à
l'heure du côté de l'union européenne
puisque maintenant les ministres des
affaires étrangères de l'union
européenne font entame une deuxième
réunion sous l'égide de l'union il
s'agira d'un tour de table entre les
états membres d'éventuelles nouvelles
sanctions européennes contre la russie
sont dans les tuyaux mais aucune
certitude au moment n'est ce pas jean
jacques guéry correspondant de france 24
à bruxelles merci jean jacques